has any of the present or past doctors
seen the anniversary of there's a sneak
peek have they had the sneak peek of
definitely runs quickly through my head
actually Matt Smith hasn't seen it yet
he hasn't seen in 3d I think yeah how
did anyone seen that that ain't no hang
on though we've sent it to 94 countries
so some people have seen it why the hell
is this not late hooray for worldwide no
I think that's the answer absolutely no
doctor has seen it don't believe
everything you have you not noticed
we've been gone around seen any old
thing all of us the doctors of
disinformation that's where they are you
notice they're here come don't be so
gradual it's the only way we can keep
secrets and secrets are good wasn't it
great when Paul McGann who had
previously told you was definitely not
involved in any way popped up on your
screen wasn't that fun yeah yeah we do
more of that let's just that's why we
that's why we wind you up a bit
sometimes in a nice and lovely lovely
way so that you'll hopefully be a little
bit more entertained hopefully though
all snarl at once
you